welcome to the show this is hilarious me
Scarlett have y'all met before I've not
met Scarlett Johansson before I just
watched her on award shows periodically
saving the universe you know yes thank
you for your service my pleasure
so what's the Ambassador prune thing
what okay so I am from a little farm
town in northern California that is the
prune capital of the world and when you
are sort of like a finky liberal gay guy
you don't always get to have a great
relationship with your conservative
little farm town okay so I would
periodically just tweet at the
California prune board I should be your
unofficial official Ambassador and then
finally I said hey if you guys don't
respond I'm taking my talents to the
California cling Peach board they were
like fine we give in you can be our
ambassador here's the thing I don't
think I've ever had a prune prunes are
delicious they are jamming they are
sophisticated French people go crazy for
them am I right Scarlett Johansson we
absolutely
can I ask you a kind of like a question
that I should probably know absolutely
um is it prune is it Plum right a
California like a prune is just a dried
plum oh I love plants and like everybody
loves plums everybody understands like
an apricot it just turns into a dried
apricot but they get weirded out when
you go from Plum to prune
um it's just the same delicious flavor
but concentrated okay you're a great
Ambassador I love prunes I'm sorry I I'm
really proud of my little farm town we
produce tons of almonds and peaches and
it's a great place I just wish it were
more okay to be you know gay or a woman
or a person of color there
that was an enormous amount of people
so wait you're also an author here we go
so my life as a goddess where did this
come from why did you want to do this oh
I just I had this story that I would
always tell my friends there's a story
from Greek mythology about a lady a
goddess who was pregnant but didn't have
a husband and people were like means I
made fun of her and she like got like
mad and pissed off and walked away and
then she was like oh wait I'm a goddess
and then turned around and turned them
all into frogs and I think that that's
an important thing to remember is that
you have amazing powers like we all have
amazing powers that we can use and when
you're down on yourself you need to
remember to use those powers in whatever
way and don't give it away don't give
way yeah I love that they all are frogs
so you you said this a while back some
people just need to find a path to being
comfortable with themselves enough that
they can be comfortable with people
around I love this quote because I think
that's so true until you're comfortable
with yourself and in your own skin how
first of all can anybody else be
comfortable with you and then also it's
reciprocal I love this why why do you
think this I think it's so real that
anytime somebody has a weird
relationship to your specificities for
me it's so frequently being gay and very
fat and it's like that's not about me
that's about them you know it's about
their issues with themselves and I I
think that one of the best things we can
do for other people is respect ourselves
and our own specificities enough to be
able to respect theirs and that's really
what this movie Bros is about is like
two white CIS gay guys who have
developed like protective mechanisms for
dealing with a homophobic world who
don't realize how much those protective
mechanisms are hurting themselves and
the people around them and them learning
to like chill out and have fun and be
comfortable with themselves yeah but
also as I was saying before Kelly I have
to tell you okay thank you so much for
how much you have taken care of me on
dance floors so many times in my life
when I needed you you showed up
where you're gonna love the next album
wait so most most of the cast and
production uh Team of bros were lgbtq
right yes that's important the entire
cast whether they're playing straight
people or queer people or trans people
are lgbtq plus we have a couple of
cameos from Iconic Divas who I believe
are part of the Plus in lgbtq plus you
know you guys have given us so much and
we owe so much back to you love you so
much okay so wait we know that Scarlett
is really into music
um and you're great at hosting a game
show so like what if we did a game like
a music game and you hosted would you be
interested I mean that sounds really fun
okay I'm into it okay
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going
[Music]